let's jump into this first story they're
coming for Trump DC Watchdog group
brings suit on behalf of Colorado voters
to remove Trump from 2024 ballot using
the 14th Amendment that's the gist of
the story here we go again
I don't know if uh it's the citizens for
responsibility nothing's in Washington
crew
claims that Trump has disqualified
himself for violating section three of
the 14th Amendment we knew that they
were trial ballooning this when they
went after a bunch of politicians over
January 6. one guy Coy Griffin out of
New Mexico I think it was actually got
removed over it
I don't know if they succeed but I do
know they're not going to stop trying to
get him removed and they need to remove
him from only one state and it doesn't
even need to be all it has to be is I
don't know how many states are not
winner take all there's a feel like
Nebraska is kind of weird but if if they
remove him from any one state
particularly a swing state that's it
he's gonna have a very hard time winning
especially he needs to win three he
doesn't need that many votes you know it
was 42 000 votes he lost by in 2020 but
this is their strategy they can't win
right now we are seeing them go after
all of these January Sixers many of many
of whom were non-violent they're trying
to generate as much anti-trump sentiment
we've got news stories about potential
Mass Medics coming back they are pulling
out all the stops and it is not even
2024. Charlie Kirk tweeting earlier that
new criminal charges May about may be
about to drop from Jack Smith pertaining
to Donald Trump
and his his uh actions pertaining to
voter machines you've got a warning
already from Jack Smith that Trump's
statements are are tampering with the
jury pool
and it's 2023. we got a whole year in
front of us and the shenanigans have
only just begun I gotta say though I I
just don't I'm kind of resigned to
accept that Trump's not going to be
president and it doesn't matter anyway
because the president ain't going to fix
this it's going to be the private sector
the president can stand by and say no
but cannot make anything happen the
public the public is going to make a
change if we're really going to have
some sort of psychological revolution in
this country it's not going to happen
from the top but the top will be
involved but I don't think placing faith
in the next guy to win the race is like
the way that we're going to save our
nation well it really was I can I can I
partially agree with what you're saying
it is a cultural shift that needs to
happen and that is happening with the
parallel economy that's being built with
Public Square as successful as they've
been with as we've already mentioned Bud
Light Target we mentioned every single
day and and now cousin T's pancake mix
challenging these World corporations the
parallel economy is the cultural shift
we need to win but in the short term you
know the long-term thing is going to be
winning the culture War the short-term
thing is yeah we're probably going to
need to criminally charge criminals and
have some accountability the idea that
you know I'll put this way Trump winning
is a key is a strategic position in
winning this ongoing cultural cold Civil
War everyone it would be great for a lot
of people but the the metaphor I'm
feeling is like you you're going to a
horse race and Trump's your horse for
instance and you're like I that guy he's
gonna win I got everything we need this
horse to win but like they own the arena
where the horse is running they set all
the rules in real time they can have new
Runners come onto the race at any moment
they can actually tell your horse to
stop running and go sit down during the
race so how do you expect that horse to
win
well first of all I want to get
something out the way I was out January
6th I was in Washington DC I was there
at the rally now I did not go to the
Capitol so FBI don't come knocking on my
damn door I did not go to the Capitol uh
but I was there and Trump had nothing to
do with people uh uh busting out windows
or whatever was going on at that Capitol
he did not tell people to Riot Trump
would Trump trump is all about peace
he's all about peace and I was there so
so them going after him for for January
6th is just straight up bogus so I just
want to get that get that out the way
because I was there now
you you are right so we do need a
really listen will things change
probably not but we still need Trump in
office we need him in office and yes the
Democrats and the damn deep state is
running this and running that but we
can't just sit back and say well if
Trump wins it doesn't really matter like
that's not the attitude to have what are
you hoping what are you hoping for with
a trump victory
like if Trump wins what what do we what
do you what do you see there well first
of all I want Trump to continue to to do
what he was doing you know he was making
this country great again he had a lot of
stuff in in store for America but also I
want Trump which a lot of people don't
want him to do oh Trump you shouldn't uh
you shouldn't go after them you
shouldn't it that whole retribution
thing is not good Trump should go after
these criminals too he should go after
these people who are causing all of this
chaos in America that's what he needs to
do and if he doesn't win who's going to
go after them I agree we are in the um I
love the politicians are just saying
stuff that they know they can't deliver
on part of the of the election cycle
where and it is as much as I do like
Vivek he's talking about he's like we
need to to ban social media until they
turn 18 I'm like that's unenforceable
you're not going to be able to do that
and that's the the name of the game
right now is telling you that they're
going to deliver on all of these
promises that we know deep down maybe
you get like what they they make 10
campaign promises you get one for ten
yeah for ten but in in this circumstance
let's say Trump says he's gonna do all
he's gonna fire people he's gonna charge
his people he was talking to Glenn Bell
Glenn Beck Glenn Beck said do you go
after these people and he's like well
you have no choice based on what they've
been doing it it's really really simple
if Donald Trump gets elected and does
not do it then he will he will go to
prison for the rest of his life his
supporters will go to prison they'll
start targeting more journalists and
lawyers which they're already doing so
it really is just pick your poison it
either it either it goes one way or the
other there's no middle and there's no
off ramp yeah either if Trump gets
elected and he goes after these people
it's arresting people you're going to
see arrests he doesn't then they start
they continue what they're already doing
in arresting Trump supporters is lawyers
and they don't stop there I mean trying
to take Trump's name off the ballot is
one of the most extreme things we have
ever seen in this country the first time
I believe it's ever been attempted to be
used and and they're now they're on
they're on a number four right extreme
they silenced the president of the
United States of America that's even
worse when they took him off of Twitter
Facebook Instagram they silenced a
sitting president a sitting president so
I so all the stuff that they're doing
now I am not surprised but we have to
play dirty we have to play the same
games that the Democrats are playing I'm
sick of these weak ass Republicans
sitting back talking about oh well well
we are above that bullsh we're going to
investigate a bunch of stuff and have
nothing come out of any of it yeah yeah
bull crap above my ass we need to we we
we have to play dirty where's Kevin
McCarthy at what is Kevin McCarthy doing
if if people if if this was if Nancy if
people were going after Joe Biden and
trying to arrest him and Nancy Pelosi if
if if uh she was still the the uh
Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi will
be knocking doors down right now now
yeah she would not be allowing
Republicans to go after Joe Biden she
would be punching back why are we not
doing the same they're way more ruthless
and with access to the media they come
out looking better than Republicans
every single time but I don't I don't
think that really matters at this point
I think more so the issue is everybody
knows that it's a facade but everyone's
just kind of going along with it yeah
it's starting to break though like I was
mentioning I I mentioned these these
four examples two positive two negative
right sound of freedom in Richmond north
of Richmond are huge net positives and
cultural victories and then you have Bud
Light and Target as two examples of
basically
our our side of things does not let it's
not left or right I always you know it's
it's constitutional republic which they
call right or whatever but it could be
you could have more liberal opinions
we're winning in terms of Freedom
Liberty Dot challenging the the woke
cult and their and their native control
they're failing look at the ADL and the
splc and the narrative that's come out
as of recently Elon Musk challenges the
ADL now ban ADL goes starts trending on
Twitter yeah X and then what is it the
the executive director guy or whatever
says that they're a bunch of white
supremacists it doesn't work anymore
dude you're just spit
it doesn't
so let them try their institutional
control is failing this is good news
that's why I'm like you got to be
careful because these videos of j6 was
getting arrested I think is intending to
provoke a response and all you got to do
right now is really simple you got to
buy pancakes
I'm not even kidding right supporting
the parallel economy make money for
yourself support companies that believe
in your values get the word out to vote
and vote in large numbers this is why
they're trying to pull Trump's name from
the belt because they can't win in any
standard circumstance Adrian Norman's
really good about this when he a lot of
his uh posts and the stuff he does with
his journalism is he talks a lot about
how people push back on the cultural
issues online he's like yeah but are you
going out to vote right are you going
out are you actually doing something
there's an old um there's a Sage Francis
song from like 2001 he was super
anti-war and he's basically talking
about how his like uh they complain
about the global war but can't overthrow
the local Joker that they voted for
everyone wants to complain nobody wants
to actually go to The Ballot Box and do
some something about it man that that
bums me out my experience with most
people in my life when I was younger I
wanted to open uh I knew these guys had
a little miniature Warehouse with a
skate ramp in it and they were like we
all pitching 100 bucks and it covers the
rent and you know we can't afford it on
our own but together and I was like dude
we should do this I go to my friends and
everyone said the same thing you build
it and then I'll think about it and I
was like dude unless we stand up
together right now and definitively
state we will do this thing it will
never happen but that was the attitude
of everyone I knew yeah and it's similar
I I just use it as an example of how we
see most things for a long time you'd
say you've got to get out go knock on
doors ask someone else will do it let me
know when you do it if I see success
I'll consider it nah we ain't doing that
no more Scott Pressler is out there
knocking on doors and doing the hard
work we we here at timcast IRL maybe
maybe we could do more you can make that
argument but I do a Morning Show and a
night show 16 hours every day talking
about trying to build influence in
telling people to to be the change you
want to see in in the world for everyone
else it's simple spend time sending out
mailers volunteer do whatever you have
to do register people to vote and and
then we win
well what do you say when people say
Well they're gonna our vote's not gonna
count you got people saying Trump trump
lost by 42 000 votes so when they come
out and they're like there's no way Joe
Biden got 81 million votes I'm like dude
yeah he got 81 million votes because New
York and Los Angeles voted in huge
numbers because they were locked in
their houses yeah but there were three
key swing states where between them
Donald Trump only needed 42 000 votes
that's it they don't have the same
lockdowns anymore people are pissed off
at Joe Biden's approval ratings in the
gutter if Trump supporters quadruple
their efforts not even if Trump
supporters just stick to their efforts
Joe Biden's vote count is going to go
down exactly you double your efforts
Trump's going to win by a healthy amount
do you think that they're that the
reason why we're starting to see all the
Articles come out again about Mass
mandates is that they're looking to rein
uh to reinstate any type of lockdowns
before the election yes they're looking
to steal the election they're doing the
um
yes removing Trump and the ballot is
cheating they're going to use the
mail-in balance to cheat but that but
see but it's not going to work this time
because a lot of Americans are not going
to stay in their homes they're not going
to put on those masks a lot and I'm
talking about people on both sides are
not going to do that so they need to so
they need to put so that's why they want
to put president Trump in prison that's
why they want to lock them up because
they can't use coven to win this time
it's not going to work they're already
nobody's falling for that they're
already doing it with like um when it
was in 2019 teen it was Tom Hanks was
the first celebrity to get coveted and
they're like oh my God if a celebrity
can get covered then I suppose I can
they're already doing this again where
they're reading like because I I cover
pop culture and news like that so I'm
seeing all these articles like celebrity
gets this celebrity so they're already
saying like uh Whoopi Goldberg gets
covered for the third time and
everybody's shocked but it's because
they're already starting to roll out the
article propaganda when they start
trying to reinstate these things thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time